so the fine folks at these Colorado
Civil Rights Commission are added again
there they're targeting Jack Phillips
and masterpiece cake shop yet again you
may remember that the the Colorado Civil
Rights Commission was rhetorically
smacked down by the Supreme Court for
their treatment of Phillips starting the
whole gay wedding cake debacle and even
though the Supreme Court punted on the
fundamental question about religious
liberty they they also made it very
clear that the Civil Rights Commission
had been hostile towards Phillips and
treated him unfairly but the the
Commission is back at it they they
haven't learned their lesson at all I'm
gonna read to you a little bit from the
daily callers report on this it says
Jack Phillips the Christian Baker who
prevailed at the US Supreme Court after
declining to create a custom wedding
cake for a gay couple followed a lawsuit
in federal court
late Tuesday suing the Colorado Civil
Rights Commission Phillips and his
attorney at the Alliance defending
freedom ADF say the Commission has
revived its campaign against him
following June's High Court decision
singling masterpiece cake shop out for
disparate treatment on the basis of the
religious beliefs now on the same day
that the High Court agreed to review the
masterpiece case so this was several
months ago over a year ago an attorney
named R autumns Gardena called Phillips
his shop and asked him to create a cake
celebrating a sex transition the caller
asked that the cake include a blue
exterior and a pink interior which is
supposed to be a reflection of
scardino's transgender identity Phillips
declined to create the cake given his
religious conviction that sex is
immutable although he did offer to sell
the caller other pre-made baked goods
now I should just add here very quickly
that
the idea that sex is immutable
unchangeable that is not just Jack
Phillips's religious conviction that is
the conviction of science of reality and
of every sane person everywhere that's
just put it another way that's not a
conviction at all that's just a fact
so Jack Phillips understands the fact
that you cannot transition your sex and
so he doesn't want to create a cake that
that celebrates this this this
impossible thing which makes sense now
in the months that followed the the
bakery received requests for cakes
featuring marijuana use sexually
explicit messages and satanic symbols
one solicitation submitted by email
asked the cake shop to create a
three-tiered white cake depicting satan
licking a sex toy phillips believes that
scar dina made all of these requests
but in any case
[Music]
three weeks after Phillips won at the
High Court the Commission issued a
probable cause determination finding
that there was sufficient evidence to
supports cárdenas claim of
discrimination
and in a somewhat strange development
the probable cause finding reads that
Phillips violated state law even though
the proceedings are still in a
preliminary stage okay so this is a I
mean you've got this this man who not
only called asking for this ridiculous
cake but then it seems like proceeded to
call many more times asking for
increasingly vulgar and ridiculous cakes
he is the one harassing Jack Phillips
yet of course the Colorado Civil Rights
Commission finds that Jack Phillips may
well be discriminating against him so
first of all let's just establish that
the the Civil Rights Commission in
Colorado is a disgrace they are
collection of despicable vengeful
bullies the whole agency should be shut
down and each of the tyrants in that
agency should be sued into personal
financial ruin these are these are very
evil people
but but here's the interesting thing
that they've done what all evil people
do eventually which is that they've kind
of dropped the masks they've they've
dropped the charade and they've made
their wickedness plain to everybody
that's what's interesting about this
this latest attack on Jack Phillips is
that it undermines
or I should say it exposes all of the
previous attacks
and it makes it clear what's always been
true which is they just hate Christians
and they want to punish Jack Phillips
for being a Christian that's all this is
about
that's all that's this did this has ever
been about and now it's painfully
obvious so let's just look at this for a
moment
there isn't in even halfway believable
pretense of rights being violated in
this case
now before with the gay wedding thing
they could always accuse Phillips of you
know making wedding cakes for four
straight people but not for gay people
so they could try to hang a
discrimination claim based on that which
which which is by the way abyss leading
way of putting it and it's also
irrelevant in any case because the idea
that just because you make a wedding
cake in one situation it means you have
to make a wedding cake in every
situation that of course is just it's
just just ridiculous there's no that's
that's that's just
there's no basis for that for that
whatsoever just because you make wedding
cakes doesn't mean that you can't be
discerning about that discrimination
it's discernment you're allowed to be
discerning about what sorts of wedding
cakes you make but any case um even that
kind of claim as absurd and misleading
as it was even that isn't valid here
because it's not like Philips has ever
made a cake to celebrate someone
remaining the same gender
there is no opposite kind of cake that
Philips sells so there's no there's
absolutely no basis for discrimination
whether you're becoming a woman or
you're becoming a man or you're becoming
a werewolf or you're staying the same
gender Philips is not providing a cake
to celebrate it
and scar Dina can't obviously claim that
he's been emotionally traumatized that's
the gay couple in the wedding cake case
they claimed you know emotional trauma
which was of course ridiculous there as
well but it's it's self-evident that in
this case this guy was laying a trap for
Phillips he was hoping to find a basis
upon upon which he could sue Jack
Phillips that that's all this was about
this was a targeted attempt
now the gay couple I think targeted
Philips also but not quite as obviously
what in the world is a gender transition
cake anyway what does that mean
is that eat that's not even a thing
if I went to the most progressive bakery
in the world
what would I would I find something like
that with is that something they have in
their up their repertoire repertoire
I say very French
he may as well have asked for a for an
abortion cake or something like that
it's the kind of cake you request when
when you want your request to be denied
and the fact that he happened he just so
happened to make this request of the
most famous Christian Baker in the
country you know he just so happened
just coincidental you know obviously it
wasn't a coincidence this was entirely
targeted so there is no hiding the real
objective this time around this is
anti-christian bigotry plain and simple
it always was all of these cases the
attacks on Christian bakers and florists
and photographers and t-shirt makers etc
they are and always have been acts of
vengeance against Christians nothing
more it's just that now it's it is it is
so obvious to everyone another thing
that we can see in this case
though this as well should have been
obvious all along is that all the stuff
we heard from gay right the rights the
gay rights crowd about you know how they
just want the the freedom to love and to
live as they wish and they want us to
mind our own business and they'll mind
their own business
and so forth all of that is nonsense ok
if they were really proponents of the
kind of live-and-let-live sort of
philosophy none of this would be
happening because what they would say is
ok some people don't want to be
personally involved in our wedding
that's fine that's their opinion that's
their right who cares
and then they would have gone about and
live their lives that's all that would
have happened
if you really are if you really just
want people to mind our business and
you're minding your own business and if
that's what this is about
then you not you wouldn't be doing any
of this you wouldn't be taking people to
court because they won't bake you a cake
but this is an effort to punish
Christians that's what this is
trying to punish Christian business
owners and more than that they're trying
to purposefully put business owners in a
situation where they have to make this
choice
and that has nothing to do with
live-and-let-live
this is about control this is about
stamping out opposing views opposing
lifestyles and exacting punishment
ironically this they are doing exactly
what they accuse Christians of doing but
which you know I've never met a
Christian who's actually interested in
doing
I've never met a Christian who was
interested in going and finding gay
people and punishing them and forcing
things on ii-i've never met that I've
never encountered that
but there are quite a lot of people in
the gay rights crowd who are interested
in doing that to Christians
now I've heard this I've heard the
justification from the gay rights crowd
well they'll they'll say well well
Christians think that our lifestyle is
sinful and that's offensive to us
okay so
why do you care what they think
they aren't doing anything to you not
hurting you
they aren't trying to drag you in the
court over it no that's what you're
doing
that's you doing that
they're just trying to live their lives
and run their businesses the way that
they want and you're you're free to
steer clear of them what do you care so
they think your lifestyles sinful so
what what does that matter to you what
does it matter to you that they have it
Jack Phillips in his little bakery in
Colorados Minor knows his own business
making cakes what do you care if he's
got that point of view bouncing around
in his head what difference does it make
to you just go live your life doesn't
matter he's not doing anything to you
he's not taking anything away from you
you know personally I am well aware that
atheists and secular people think that I
am as a Christian stupid superstitious
backwards etc etc I'm well aware of that
and you know what they're allowed to
hold that view
there they can think it doesn't bother
me that they think that they can they
can they can think that now if they say
it to my face I'll argue with them about
it I'll defend myself and if they go out
in public preaching it I will engage
them and I'll present my side of the
story but I don't seek them out
specifically to try and punish them for
their beliefs I don't sit around
scheming ways that I can entrap an
atheist I don't do that or I don't I
don't think about ways that I might
force him to do something that makes him
uncomfortable and goes against his
atheist convictions I don't do that
because I'm a rational adult
so
if you're a member of the gay left and
it offends you that some people
disapprove of the things that you do and
the way that you live okay
That's Life that's life that's just what
it means to live in America you know you
got to just deal with that that's all
you have to deal with it because we all
have to deal with that no matter who you
are no matter what you do there are
people out there who disapprove of you
and or at the very least disapprove of
some of the things you do some of the
things you believe that's the case for
literally every person on earth so
you're no different in that regard
that's not persecution you're not being
persecuted just because people disagree
you're not
no persecution let me tell you something
what's happening to Jack Phillips that
is per this is persecution this is a
government body coming after him
repeatedly to ruin him for his beliefs
you want to know what person that is
persecution
so if you've got government bodies
coming after you to personally ruin you
and destroy you for your lifestyle well
then then you have a case made that
you're being persecuted but that's not
happening to you it is happening to Jack
Phillips and it's happening to
Christians but Christian business owners
that is what legal government
persecution looks like
so I'm sorry I just I have no sympathy
for the for the you know the the people
that go and pretend that they've been so
offended its own won't make them a cake
or provide flowers to them for the
wedding and then they set out to destroy
the person I've got no sympathy for
those people
because what they're doing is
disingenuous it's in bad faith
there they are laying booby traps and
just waiting for a Christian business
owner to walk into it that's what's
going on and I have no sympathy for it
and you know the
the live-and-let-live philosophy that no
that's not personally my guiding
philosophy in life I'm not I'm not much
of a libertarian
but if that is the if that is the the
philosophy that you claim if you claim
that that's how you then then it's got
to go both ways
can't be just let me live you know let
me live as I want but I'm gonna still
try to force myself on you you can't do
that
it's got a it's got to go both ways
that's all thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening Godspeed